después de seis meses de escolarización
en línea los menores de varios países de
europa vuelven a las aulas en este curso
junto a los lápices de colores y los
libros el material escolar incluye el
gel desinfectante y mascarillas no
dejaban de despertarse diciendo es la
hora de ir a la escuela el martes
francia bélgica y reino unido- abrieron
sus escuelas de nuevo pero la inusual
vuelta al cole está marcada por las
estrictas medidas de seguridad
sanitarias impuestas para los profesores
y estudiantes horarios más cortos lavado
de manos constantes distancia de
seguridad entre los pupitres y
mascarillas a menudo obligatorias unas
medidas necesarias pero que podrían
dificultar el aprendizaje de los más
pequeños o válidos y vamos a forzarlos a
hablar más alto también será parte del
proceso de aprendizaje y nos causará
problemas de pronunciación o la conoces
yo creo que va a ser complicado porque
sabe conflictivo y 9 españa pese a
registrar el mayor aumento de contagios
en europa también iniciará las clases a
mediados de septiembre las escuelas se
están preparando para el polémico
retorno pero los docentes critican el
constante cambio de las directrices y
exigen mejores garantías de seguridad
después de que madrid cancelará la
convocatoria de pruebas serológicas a
los profesores debido a las
aglomeraciones